>> MORE PROOF THAT NO ONE IS
SAFE WHEN IT COMES TO THE CRIME
CRISIS IN AMERICA.
EVEN OUR CHILDREN.
SHOCKING SURVEILLANCE VIDEO
SHOWING CAREER CRIMINAL THUGS,
PUNKS, PREVIOUSLY ARRESTED OVER
40 TIMES SUCKER PUNCHING, GET
THIS, A 4-YEAR-OLD IN THE MIDDLE
OF TIMES SQUARE A BLOCK FROM
HERE.
MAMA BEAR INSTINCTS KICKING IN
IMMEDIATELY TACKLING THE PERPS
TO THE GROUND UNTIL POLICE
ARRIVED TO ARREST THEM.
NYPD OFFICER SAID WHO NEEDS THE
DA, IN REFERENCE TO THE NEW DA
HERE.
THE MAMA TOOK CARE OF JUSTICE,
THE DETECTIVE SAID, THE OLD
FASHION WAY.
HERE'S HOW SHE DESCRIBED THE
SCENE.
>> I TURNED AROUND AND THE BABY
IS SCREAMING, CRYING.
I SAID WHAT HAPPENED?
SHE SAID THAT GUY HIT ME.
I GRABBED HIM.
I FELL ON MY BACK WITH HIM.
HE WAS KICKING.
I DON'T THINK HE SHOULD EVEN BE
OUT.
>> I JUST WANT TO START WITH THE
LADY.
EMILY, I DON'T KNOW IF YOU TAKE
THE SUBWAY.
BEFORE I GET TO EMILY, THIS
WHOLE SCENARIO IS HAPPENING AS
AT LEAST EIGHT PEOPLE WERE
ATTACKED IN THE SUBWAY SYSTEM
OVER THE WEEKEND AFTER THE MAYOR
ANNOUNCED A NEW SAFETY PLAN TO
CRACK DOWN ON SAFETY CRIME.
I ALSO WANT TO MENTION CHICAGO,
WHICH ALREADY SUFFERED SEVEN
MURDERS, CHICAGO SUFFERED SEVEN
MURDERS SINCE FRIDAY, SINCE
FRIDAY.
WE STILL HAVE ALL DAY TODAY, THE
HOLIDAY WEEKEND.
ARE YOU AFRAID?
>> I DON'T ANY MORE.
I WALK TO AND FROM WORK IN THE
SNOW BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO
RISK IT.
I HAVE THE LUXURY THAT I DON'T
HAVE TO TAKE THE SUBWAY.
NOT EVERYONE DOES.
PART OF THE PLAN IN THIS STATE
INCLUDES AN EXPANSION OF A LAW,
A 19D 99 STATUTE THAT ALLOWS
JUDGES TO FORCE OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT FOR MENTALLY ILL
PEOPLE.
MY POINT IS, A REASON A LOT OF
THESE LAWS ARE ON THE BOOK IS
BECAUSE OF A HORRIFIC EVENT, A
TRAGEDY, A LIFE THAT WAS TAKEN
THAT RESULTED IN A LAW TO BE
PASSED TO PREVENT THOSE HORRIBLE
TRAGEDIES TO BE DONE.
A MANIAC CHILD MOLESTER IN LOS
ANGELES THAT WAS HEARD GLOATING
OVER THE PHONE.
THE ISSUE WAS THE DA, BECAUSE HE
PROSECUTED HIM AT THE TIME AS A
JUVENILE, MADE THE JUDGE UNABLE
TO DO ANYTHING.
JUDGE BASICALLY SAID, MY HANDS
ARE TIED.
THE DA SAID, MADE A STATEMENT TO
FOX NEWS AND SAID THE LEVEL OF
REMORSE ABOUT THE HARM HE CAUSED
THE CHILD.
IF I HAD KNOWN MORE, I WOULD
HAVE HANDLED THINGS DIFFERENTLY.
>> WHY?
>> THE FACTS ARE WHAT CONVEY
THAT.
THEY DON'T NEED REMORSE TO TELL
A DA WHAT THEY NEED.
I NEED A DA TO DO THEIR JOB.
THE KIDS WHO DON'T HAVE A MOM TO
ATTACK THE PERP, THEY ARE
RELYING ON THE DA TO ENFORCE THE
LAWS.
THIS HAS ALL BEEN ERODED THANKS
TO DEMOCRATS.
>> IN CLEVELAND THIS WEEKEND, WE
HAD THE NBA ALL-STAR GAME.
ONE MORE THING TODAY.
MY PAL DETECTIVE STEVE SAID THEY
JUST CLOSED ANOTHER RITE AID
BECAUSE OF SHOPLIFTERS GONE WILD
WITH NO ENFORCEMENT, PROSECUTION
OR CONSEQUENCE.
MY ONCE NICE SAFE NEIGHBORHOOD
HAS GONE TO SHAT.
TWO MURDERS YESTERDAY IN
CLEVELAND DURING ALL STAR
WEEKEND.
>> I WALKED TO WORK THE OTHER
DAY.
POSTING NYPD OFFICERS OUTSIDE OF
WALGREEN'S.
THINK ABOUT THE OTHER THINGS
THEY SHOULD BE DOING.
YOU GOT TO DO IT BECAUSE THINGS
ARE OUT OF CONTROL.
YOU TALK ABOUT POLITICIANS
SITTING BACK AND WATCHING.
YOU HAVE A DEMOCRAT DA AND MAYOR
DEMOCRATS CONTROL THE NYPD.
THEY CONTROL THE FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR HERE.
STATE LEGISLATORS.
TWO DEMOCRAT SENATORS.
HAS CHUCK SHUMER SAID A DAMN
THING?
>> WHERE'S CHUCK?
>> WHERE'S AOC?
>> REMEMBER, THEY ARE STEALING
BABY FORMULA.
THAT'S THE ISSUE.
SO WHEN SOMEONE WALKS THROUGH
TIMES SQUARE AND CLOCKS A YOUNG
KID LIKE THAT, I WOULD BE
EMBARRASSED AS A DEMOCRAT IN NEW
YORK TO HAVE TO WATCH MOMS COME
OUT AND TACKLE THIS GUY UNTIL
COPS ARRIVE.
GUY NEVER SHOULD HAVE BEEN OUT
ON THE STREET LIKE THIS.
YOU HAVE 125,000 EITHER TOURISTS
OR CITIZENS COME THROUGH TIMES
SQUARE EVERY SINGLE DAY,
GERALDO.
THAT'S TWO FOOTBALL STADIUMS
WORTH OF PEOPLE.
IT IS THE CENTER OF THE WORLD.
BIGGEST URBAN NEXUS IN THE
ENTIRE WORLD.
>> TRUE.
>> IT IS THE DEMOCRATS'
RESPONSIBILITY TO KEEP THIS
PLACE SAFE.
NOT ONLY LITTLE KIDS GETTING
CLOCKED.
YOU HAVE RAPES.
YOU HAVE SHOOTINGS.
YOU HAD STABBINGS.
YOU HAVE HOMICIDES IN TIMES
SQUARE.
THIS CANNOT HAPPEN IN A CITY
LIKE THIS.
POLITICIANS HAVE TO STOP BLAMING
GUNS AND REPUBLICANS AND COVID
AND BLAME THEMSELVES.
>> I THINK ONE THING I REMEMBER
FROM THE OLD DAYS, DANA.
THE GUARDIAN ANGELS ARE
EVERYWHERE.
MAYBE CITIZENS HAVE TO FIGHT
BACK.
MAYBE THE OLD DAYS HAVE COME
AGAIN.
>> A MOM WAS TRYING TO PROTECT
HER KID.
THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE TO.
>> THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE TO.
THINK ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THERE'S CRIME HAPPENING ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THE NEXT STEP IN THE PROCESS IN
SAN FRANCISCO IS FOR THE LIBERAL
PROSECUTOR THERE.
HE'S UP FOR A RECALL ON JUNE
7TH.
MIGHT NOT TURN OUT THE SAME WAY
AS THE SCHOOL BOARD.
ALL EYES COULD BE ON THAT.
LAST THING I WANT TO SAY, WE
WERE GOING TO HAVE THIS GUEST ON
THIS MORNING WHOSE 9-YEAR-OLD
DAUGHTER WAS CAUGHT IN THE
CROSSFIRE.
NEVER SHOULD HAVE BEEN SHOT BUT
SHE WAS.
BABIES ARE BEING HIT.
THEY ARE BEING KILLED.
SOMETIMES IT'S MISTAKEN
IDENTITY.
SOMETIMES IT'S BECAUSE OF A ROAD
RAGE INCIDENT.
THAT IS THE KIND OF THING THE
SOCIAL FABRIC REALLY STARTS TO
CRUMBLE.
YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
PRESIDENT BIDEN CAME TO NEW YORK
TO HAVE HIS PICTURE TAKEN WITH
MAYOR ADAMS.
IT'S ABOUT TO BE MARCH 1ST AND
THIS IS NOT LOOKING LIKE IT IS
GOING TO GET BETTER.
>> I HAVE A 3-YEAR-OLD DAUGHTER.
IF THAT HAPPENED TO MY DAUGHTER,
THE ONLY PERSON GOING TO JAIL IS
ME BECAUSE I'M PUTTING YOUR SOUL
IN THE GRAVE, SENDING YOUR SOUL
TO HELL.
WHEN WE GO TO WAR, WE MOVE OUR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
WE DO IT TO PROTECT THE
INNOCENCE IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT REALLY TICKS ME OFF TO SEE
OUR POLITICIANS NOT DO THE SAME
THING.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS PUT A
LITTLE BIT OF CAREER COLLATERAL
OUT THERE TO PUT BAD PEOPLE IN
JAIL.
WHEN THERE'S A WHOLE CLASS OF
AMERICANS WILLING TO DIE TO DO
THE SAME THING.
IT GOES WITH THE MASK MANDATES,
ALL THE WAYS WE ARE LETTING